[Music]
in copycat Maile news submitted by ham
and cheese sandwiches aren't great Miley
Cyrus is being accused of plagiarizing
two artists work again again I'm scared
enough Miley Cyrus why do you know so
much about Miley Cyrus it happens so you
know what's funny that wouldn't surprise
me though if Bart did follow Miley Cyrus
just knows random [ __ ] he just gets into
random ass [ __ ] all the time damn for
Joe to call your [ __ ] random that's
welcome frame that's random that is
Randall I mean I'm random dude okay so
she looks like she wore that before he
knows this in order to promote her
recently released EP called she is
coming something to play video the
beginning part is her promo and then
that the parts after that is the artist
that people were saying that she's
copying okay so this artist name is
Stephanie Sarli that looks like a blue
suit a vagina oh [ __ ] oh my lord the
artist like she's known for using fruit
I've seen that way so they put lotion on
this this is going to town all those
things well pay attention gentlemen
that's the way to do it which one all of
them that one yeah everything look at
that well I feel like they just caught
me that one's real that was real that
one's beautiful
I've been doing all that so I don't know
about that one oh my god this is [ __ ]
crazy that's a Bible that's the black
ball
that's hot I should do that after I'm
hungry
I want to [ __ ] a food Miley's that a big
potato it's a parent mean it makes sense
though I don't do this this is Miley's
again wait wait wait what's the
difference oh I thought I was watching
all the same thing no she told you the
first time
and the recipes are leave artwork
copying those because I thought it was
one entire thing I know but I copies
petrol saying like it looks like it's
one thing yeah like people are saying
you should copyright [ __ ] rubbing
fruit yeah right how flowers look like
[ __ ] well everyone knows that a banana
looks like a dick certain fruits look
like by the way that it's shot in the
way that it's done it looks like one
long video I mean I guess aspired by but
I like hot cheese coming under fire
because nobody knows that it's an entire
creative team that did it they ditch
this idea to Miley she's like oh that
sounds like because she's not someone I
should know [ __ ] yeah oh yeah looks
exactly the same it just seems like
they're highly inspired by the other
person even though it's exactly what it
feels like such a simple idea not to
knock or throw shade on the artist but
it just feels like such a simple idea
that you can accidentally even do it
that's a complete ripoff in my eyes oh
really it just feels like they pay
homage to it well I think I think if I
just was done in the 60s that would be
homage classic and then it's kind of
like Tarantino right yeah like that to
me looks like a carbon copy with just a
different background oh that's why I
couldn't tell the difference I was like
that looks like one long video that's
connected it doesn't look like two
completely separate video I guess
because for me I'm like some flowers the
white [ __ ] because you seen those a
series of paintings by the artist
Virginia some [ __ ] not sure but she
makes nature look like vagina whatever
so for you you're saying like fruit
itself can look like a vagina but what
she's doing with it but the art is a
complete ripoff the idea is so nothing
big yeah yeah that I'm like I can see
how people can even accidentally do the
exact I think it's what she's doing with
the art it makes it unique I think the
execution is a ripoff so the concept is
not a ripoff
that looks like [ __ ] that looks like
dick but the way that it's shot though
everything is almost exactly the same
it's just white background versus orange
black either way
they can shot what other way can they
shoot that though they have to get a
clear shot so has to be over it could
have been someone holding the [ __ ]
thing I mean there's just so many
different things right yeah it could
have been a chick holding of itself
great it's still a female's hand versus
a male or like I don't know it's to me
I'm like that looks like an exact ripoff
top-down shot everything it just looks
like the same person did it it's such a
commonly done thing like it's so simple
like Gio said like anyone could have
done that I think it's only under fire
because she's a celebrity so patents are
not about ideas they're about the
application of ideas it's how you use
the idea makes it unique and so that's
Joe's saying it's like yeah it's unique
because of the way that you're doing the
execution it's almost the same I mean it
is the same yeah to me it's a complete
ripoff to looks exactly since I thought
it was one video until the end and I was
like oh wait that's what I think it's
not because one's super high quality the
other one looks more like a phone or
whatever but the part that I think feels
more Amish is they're not in the same
genre so you know if you have like two
graffiti artists and you're like wait
this guy looks exactly like that then
it's different but if one guy is a catch
ildren book guy but in his walls is this
guy's art then it's like oh I see where
he gets his inspiration from it's like
it's not like one rapper copying another
rapper it's like how there's a movie
called Vice and there's a TV show called
vice and they're two completely
different things yeah yeah so Stephanie
she says that she was upset that my
Cyrus and her team have done this
because it directly chips away at her
livelihood an ability to feel creative
openness at times while dealing with
this and so she's saying that it's
painful to see your actual art and
expressions and concepts just completely
plagiarized just for money for cloud
it's jaw-dropping do you think why me it
makes you sick inside I could kind of
see that though if she has like create a
really unique theme that she's barely
able to eat off of and then if someone
comes and makes millions off of without
her getting royalties I can see that
being really yeah so she's saying that
she also suspects that someone is
deleting comments under that post
alleging plagiarism because there have
been other people that brought this to
her attention cuz she has four hundred
and eleven thousand followers on
dad has a good amount the food [ __ ]
artist yes definitely sir they're not
small fries
she's even verified does she go buy food
[ __ ] artist I'm not I've got some
minutes for verification yesterday I got
rejected what a food [ __ ] well there's
people with like 40 grand in there hates
us over there it's 75 thousand and I'm
verified so [ __ ] you Gina you have 75
yeah that's pretty good
I'm verified everywhere cuz when you're
doing that [ __ ] roll five four three
two one thing you were only have 40,000
I know I work for Facebook the one that
Owens Instagram and I said I was chosen
to stream on Instagram I literally work
for you and you can't verify I love the
disrespect blatantly this is you're so
petty and so am I and I just love it
right like it's just oh my god and then
I feel like someone to 500 he only has
75 25 [ __ ] verified
[ __ ] I've only posted like three
other pictures ever me too remember in
the headline to artist I thought I'd
tell you about the other one yeah so
Miley Cyrus you posed with a cake that
read that reads abortion is healthcare
and so the artist that created the
identical cake came out and say said
like what the [ __ ] this is my work town
oh so she's just straight cop and left
or right yeah her team our team yeah
that's true so this is the artist
reposting Miley Miley sing so she's
licking a cake says abortion is health
care like literally everything about it
is identical to her cake no no a bit bit
the cake one it's by the sweet feminist
that's all ran out of space when they
wrote the other day
hey when that happens I'll ever
that's horrible super back to the okay
that sucks oh you can't see if there's
sprinkles on the side there is here's
the thing there's sprinkles everything
Miley Cyrus does is more and more
annoying this chick is like maybe the
most annoying person I've ever seen I
get any media I've ever watched her on
what's that the voice what she's pretty
cool on this so the way she handled this
one she immediately responded to comment
from the Baker saying something like hi
we saw the image online and didn't
realize it was yours we will absolutely
tag you for your work horrible oh
because they also said if you could
please correct your post as we're going
to make sure you have all the credit you
deserve thanks for sharing your art
inspiring us she ends up saying like
while I acknowledge your tag although it
should be in the caption itself it
doesn't change the fact that my work was
used without mic without compensation
and without my consent and it is not
sufficient permission yeah and not only
that but now this Baker who is also
verified by the way she thank you for
that to me thank you oh she has even
less followers oh my god [ __ ] kill me
dude I I think she got verified because
of this because you know how they say if
you're sensing seven news article of my
name's in it on my okay people talk
about them here I've said [ __ ]
magazine covers that I've been on if
you're with Instagram please don't do it
because it's so funny that she's not
very fun here's my thing it's like she
can't look just holding a cake this is
abortion as health care is not annoying
but the way that she has to put her
[ __ ] Talman in the video we should
stuck her tongue out every 30 seconds
it's like alright we got it right that's
what she's like she reminds me of like
these 15 year old girls I want to high
school with who thought they were like
[ __ ] extreme because they're like
they went like this in pictures
yeah you're [ __ ] one of those you
know what sucks though that her team was
like oh we'll give you credit it's like
a slap in the face cuz it's like I will
tag you it's like no [ __ ] take it down
cuz I didn't give you [ __ ] permission
yeah down so this is in collaboration
with Marc Jacobs and Planned Parenthood
that she created like a hoodie so
they're trying to may raise money and
awareness for Planned Parenthood I'm
sure she also humped the hoodie or
something the whole cake thing was she
has a liket be right for but and so the
other one was for her EP that sucks how
come no one copies my work they did it's
called Saturday Night Live in Conan and
oh [ __ ] yeah we had she never blamed
them it's their writers they do lazy
work they watch some show what happen we
had the ultra v-neck skit that we
created and then almost identically the
format and everything SNL has the same
one there's a few other ones that our
fans caught but then we did a naked spa
challenge at the Etta at a Korean spa
and then I saw an opponent yeah Kody's
super millions so we don't have to sit
here anymore so he's expensive I know it
costs more decision you don't have
anything else to do stop suing people
I'm your lawyer now I'm just gonna start
suing everyone I had anything for used
to one of my bids and I knew one of the
writers us so I'm like damn this is kind
of extra cold and you didn't see yeah
Nathan for you is the Comedy Central
show oh yeah they took one of my bits
like the whole the whole the whole troll
bit and then I found out that one of the
writers was a guy that I actually knew
and worked with I'm like dad that's uh
yeah
[Music]